[Applaudissements]
dans mon coeur
les contours assez sur l'attrait pour la
12è de balances ton pas s'arrête là
deuxième là on va partir jusqu'au bout
de la nuit on à du gros gros dossier là
dans les loges là déjà ça s'embrouille
et c est pas mal
j'abrège content de votre immersion en
direct on est bien avec mon jean luc et
un bâton public est beau et d'égalité
[Applaudissements]
on va te les a trouvés mais très bien
qui est le public ou les chroniqueurs
ont très très disciplinés non c'est vrai
ouais non je plaisante
et c'est ça le cador le cador cegid a
lui-même mais c'est vrai quand il faut
le vouvoyer à une brusque leverdez
bonjour monsieur vers des chaussures cn
vers des cadors est tôt car c'est vous
[Applaudissements]
j'adore c'est pour vous est ce que
voulait une question alors j'adore les
questions c'est vrai je n'y réponds
jamais on regarde
bonjour je m'appelle michel j'ai
remarqué que cyril hanouna disait assez
facilement des gens qu'ils recevaient
que c'était des génies
donc je voulais savoir s'il connaît
autant de génie pourquoi il n'en a pris
aucun dans son équipe
pression c'est une expert en questions
et cela comprend gervais jamais mais je
pense que vous avez tort
il n'y a que des gens très vive dans la
bande de cire il a commencé par bernard
montiel qui l'a prouvé lors de la venue
des black eyed peas sais pas si vous
vous souvenez
après le ravage les chroniques raté en
bord de seine là bas et d'un seul coup
il iam le leader de groupe va avoir un
titre en voyant christine kelly ah oui
trouvant qui a ressemblé beaucoup à sa
chanteuse
donc ils veulent interpeller pour rappel
le problème c'est qu'entre lui et
christine il y avait bernard qui a tout
pris pour lui un génie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
déjà les black eyed peas avant contre
patrick white systems craquer comme
toujours compagnie croit toujours qu'on
parle de lui et montiel quel moment le
mec s'est dit mais c'est vrai je ressens
beaucoup aux grands moments dans les
lives de la venue de niño erin qu'un
achat d'or c'est vraiment sous préfet
raymond aux manceaux préférence moment
alors oui je me sens particulièrement le
même soit on avait aussi jean pierre
descombes en plateau le roi du ni oui ni
non et belles rencontres
je pense que jean piat bien qui fait la
chanson même s'il n'a pas dû écouter les
paroles
[Applaudissements]
marini
retraités
[Applaudissements]
aux açores
g
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
auxerre legault
on avait
[Applaudissements]
à mon sens
début juin
non plus
les
j'ai venir attention la la la la la la
ces ces deux très bon ami à moi
rim'k inigo et en plus ce titre c'est
mon titre préféré en ce moment quoi on
voit bien que vous êtes complètement à
la ramasse du tour complètement jogging
en veste en jean avec un t-shirt
ridicule attention attention talent
d'animateur la banane le titre
exceptionnel c'est sûrement le contraste
une grosse paire de couilles jean pierre
descombes c'est encore celle où qu'ils
soient
je mets du rouge à lèvres sur le gland
détourné alors mais arrêter mais s'est
dit d'accord mais bien sûr on aime le
relais mais les gens qui prennent soin
d'eux parlait la pâtisserie le gland bah
oui c'est devancé la pâtisserie mais
dans ce qu'elle a mangé un gland et
avait de la balade
alors jean pierre sais pas si vous êtes
au courant mais s'adapter énormément
avoue jean-pierre des combats il fait
des efforts il essaye de personnaliser
ces questionnaires par exemple pour
faire jouer syrie dit oui ni non
il s'est dit que ça serait bien employer
des mots du vocabulaire du mozart de la
présentation alors c'est quoi le mot
préféré de cyril qui suis plus un indice
c'est par astral chérie chéri chéri
donc ma beauté regardez la presse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si l'elysée
g
[Musique]
mais
[Applaudissements]
une bonne foi et mais les gens de la
graine
franchement c'est que j'adore le
courrier lyon si les tracas qui dise
comment on allait d un bar par le trac a
d'ailleurs il faut qu'on parle de la
rencontre entre les eaux dont bois et
maxime guinea la semaine dernière alors
ils sont bien trouvés tous les deux ans
l'union impossible alors pour vous
saisissez bien je veux d'abord vous
passez un extrait qui est pas
spécialement drôle mais qui expliquent
la suite la leo découvrait que maxime
avait préparé plein d'autres pour
l'émission il ya préparé des messieurs
voilà trop propre trop gay ni quoi et on
arrive maintenant à la conversation la
plus surréaliste de la semaine voire de
l'année voire de toute l'histoire de tp
alors pour que vous compreniez bien il
faut savoir qu'à chaque pub un assistant
nous à part des petites bouteilles d'eau
marqué nos initiales pour pas gâcher ce
pmp on pense à l'écologie est exactement
important alors que là nous sommes à la
pause publicitaire suivante
l'assistant cherche dans sa caisse la
bouteille de maxime et pour chambrer le
premier la classe les on va dire que ça
va être une bouteille de la drogue à
l'intérieur un pour faire une blague
elle n'aurait pas dû
[Musique]
mk
g
mais non
direct
je vous assure il est inodore j'adore ma
dernière j'avais deux minutes sur
l'extracteur de jeu du je vous ai dit
allez on passe et objets dans ces
moments si blizzard ne touche pas à mon
poste
[Musique]
je pose des questions denis chroniqueur
c'est nous c'est nous qui vont de paire
gagner
[Musique]
on
tuchan cette chanson c'est lié aux
clients non maxime les maximes c'est
jeanne mas
[Musique]
les séries les cherry a reculé vous
toujours
[Musique]
bonjour
les données
[Musique]
à lesquin
vous n'êtes pas mariée vous non moi ça
m'est arrivé
[Musique]
ça
grand écran qu'adorent
[Applaudissements]
la flèche la flèche est de retour bravo
bravo merci vous donner un peu plus
houleux mais comme ça on adore balesi
alors plaisir et on commence par la tête
magique de géraldine maillet qui écoute
les expulsions de benjamin castaldi
pendant la pub on sent qu'elle a envie
de faire un effort qu'elle voudrait le
comprendre mais on fait simple et
efficace sur le podium parce qu'on ne
sait pas qu on est à la bourre c'est
qu'on doit tout y est encore tout ça
j'ai rien entendu
il disait que ce soir à la cantine y
avait des frites au jour d'aujourd'hui
il faut alors pas au jour d'aujourd'hui
j'en ai marre de taper sur nrj12 d'avoir
au jour d'aujourd'hui c'est ça le faire
[Musique]
ça
le jour où tu es
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'amour
[Musique]
vim
[Applaudissements]
quelle économie
[Musique]
pour vous lever
je suis super content d'être entouré de
sommités la télévision
[Musique]
soro
jean-pierre six tours
[Musique]
et la chanteuse est soulagée j'ai
l'épaule à la roue et surtout le talent
différencier c'est pas moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de quoi offrir la télé moi non pas du
goût du capitaine boukistan capital
boukistan viagra aux non plus pourquoi
la famille jaune